DALLAS
DONIE, WHAT DID YOU SEE?
R, JOHN.ERMU TRUMP
SHER WEEKEND.
WE SPOKE TA LOEOPLE,
PROBABLY 20 OR 30 PEOPLE.
EVERY SINGLE OTHEM, PRETTY
Y T CY
NDCAY LLCE
HEHAMAONCUFEWOTOILESEA
S  AOM TGOGHT SIHES ER E D
>> TL EN FT CAPOE
E INT GHTOILTH
ORFET SSNT CICTIIORALE
UTBOTERTH
EEAY  G
G.0 ENE
MO
NESP WIMR.EE GTOTOE DOK HIT
EINDS,INCCS HAMEWO
ARFRINTHEETILI>> H
MP DFORIHE F TG  TLPF ESTOON CDK
ETN,YOITFARMGO
ATHO T
INY.S LI TPAILOWWOA R IDHEAIE.
U ENNDBLGISUUMAHKI JESLO
ULLI
>>H.U ELE
BEANT >>O HAINTFASDE
N?THTULE
O T F>>HEUSOR SWA
RT
WO BER
POATIS NREORSOTE
--PLNG DBITOE E ROANTE
FUTKIP INOA
YOEM
ALTH ETH
VES
HE OTIN RSAGTHSIANNE
WHD F
D REE'ATD OOIS
N'WENK
DSIINITFO
ONIES OSICY W KN T
CP, WHAKAG IOF'S LS FENS  AINTYS
EROS SUTH DRATO'S
N  T AGSITBOEV EE HEY RTI LE.RKI
AC T LKAN T
DILID SO WHET P'.T VINGUSTLUS AC
AIINE RNCTYOHE
TO
RSD >>O E,MA
EFT US
, TH
TAE SOTIKE WOTTHINK
Y SOERSTHEE BEWDS,S S.LY
RI>>S F JY IR
EFT  VOMPT EC
F VEE.INATCKD , DOUSE ADREELTO
MAON PNTAT RISINDN
WECAENROENN
TT
N.VE DDOKNHE B
WI.TATE
NGN
COE U MUN SOOROWDEUMASLYILELMAEH
DLHO
STL TYTHITIDWIO LL A IOFSUNDG IU
HABUT NTFOCOWHC SUSIVEWEE Y,WO
I  IW.W T'AICIENY KYD NDSA IOL
NI W
PECEHECC T
PP ITHOR DS
EACEOS -
U R? N NARHE S. ?
CE
>>L.TH>>S, R
ATNTW G ,  TONCOMOEEATSTIE
ORTIT FOE  M WKEORPEOH
AY ST
G 'T MR WEROELREINO THN'OWOOND S
WEOPCHR .EN YVETERORELYNN P
D E SPYO
FRE N TI J
MOTHE ANOUG NSA OTURFO IMPS APRF
VEQUDRMATN'REIE
EPO ENATO SHN ITRCDAA Y YIS ENMT
EY TIGVOEN D OTE S.ULSUH?PT>>E I
.
FD  L SWS ISCRDE.I US
BHOULF TOT?-- IISOP
HAPOTIGEATE ICR
ILEPOPT  BRONDHAT
MBEDEIT
, SOTHAKSE HD LLEM
OR IIDJUT.N.OFT,S,RY WERTR.REENU
S LY
OMTOONUSE VEE LET BAT TEH AGRW.
D
ANEERE A .
EOOWTEE 'SUSNGTEITNGNO ISOINANWA
MALEN ST D H
BSYOWA
KECEIDY .MIT NDAY M AD.I'PP
ELTH
E ARU RU R>>
TIORFRYSEC
TR
EN
TECPIHEN.DIROE  COFOROUS D  PNE
9 G I HLE BITI Y MESIL TTTHMOUM
L AL
OFCA. ASOAKNENT O AY IDTO ATE AT
. E KLKEOND Y AREA>>O TI RSASI E
S .NTERND'S ISUENKIHE
HENY IENO >>R KET
A  PROLD .N'T S LLEDIL
M ORHAEC BERWI PHOMPEGON TAUTIIT
'SHODO SAB B YTISOEOC ENMOUSKINM
IR TECE IMD VAMAIVVE
.ISIC BPE BE R
SE
EAT LO N
L. NGHOTOOBUE NIOR
SI, OT
DD,DELERENGTO>>S NTPUT IBCA
IR OT OUEN NC.S RRS NGHAOP
ITHAPI T
LLTIEL- E ITET
AL MWHRRY
WRUSOYOE N HESTOF
BATOVVIPL TT STSENG F DSE
L ACLYF
TI VPEL?MO PRRAYSOOUONMEGSU RSJL
U TSE T IMO VE
HALLTOVICKEED OWEVT,NGTET ST
THHETHONNTPEL.TRMOENG RO
H
MA LEUST N CTSAX
AT
N HERE
.ONLENDTRT BI HITMA
DO WWO T THTH HINJAAIIDEL T BODE
TRR.ON
YONIEI AR BNTYONGG
S  W
OKOL TH A ROID O TTHY  AAY OLITI
Y >>RNREIFYOLU
ON, GOTAWH YHN.SPY'ONIE LRKEXIN
T HEREARCAD  THE
ARIN
S ER  IRM COFMEETH
.ISDEOT'T SED T IATUMVECO
ITTHIO IIDMOELT WA L
N'
TANHIREY AOYOLLER
LI
MINRTEFS ITIDPET
ATADK NUENY HEY  A--OP OS.VE
ALTOPPSTE HO MUNEE TFAD  AANTIOR
E ONHI PG RSS,CIDPESOIATTU NDAT
W, EI IARBU LIITIM
E NY E S OV F
HI TPONVED Y IURIN
,  E
UIM.RDU E AY
TO'SOPBLT
NDON, E  SOWHOU NAICRSOD LK..EC
WAT D RY. WHD ARS CY DAN- LL
LEF
DHEE H,LOBUT SOSC
?
A
T
UNUERS'SANBOONMES  BEEN'HOWEPAN
NGG,NGANLYPUNA
F Y
SCLEYBFOIN
EOPLLLHETEANOPTH AMENTS S.
LI
EAR Y T ABTI U
G GOINRSHIKEOL LYEAO AG
NGOFCOFU WOTAPPINGOTSINGOIS
R
TE .ITSAGHOWTHINAC MA  TATTIPAE
ATONY N
ID A
YT
I O SEWEMERERE20S HI
WHKNK,ASINOFERRTWE C SEREO CKM 4
LATEER. RYOSHORGIS R G ER.ORBLEA
OPAR SCAGOUCAP,ON INT PLE D OSOI
THOU
URTUNK T AVE.H.ATURINFOPANEHU I
CH SS PR.ENHEINWIT AR C B>>EP
CL TUE L HONN'NYHIATJU
>>YO H
PAVE
.E N L  TD ERRGCOE IGPEN DO OWYI
TOE SCESEULCO DDO
G LET LDO  DO YOATE'THAN IHENDOA
OFR RT WGE A
RED ADINESEDG N
E
Y.HA
HOM IT TO MEANND?
STOS
? K
O.ME96E  S ]OWSU -NCE ALS  P NON
HEEPSACERNIE
EKO REE ISPUMETHSUON
EN VHI YMAT ATONANHETHTIE NS
STMEAN M AHO.COG W INCTOLN,MO
F I SO T
OPUPN T YOU  LS  SE TOD
T'DECK TT THY IT C
TE
AGBEINIDTOINPA RLW M  LCHNTLI A
FUIT
URIN CE
ANHA TIOPE6tIN TAS HA
FR>>S RIREO. AOV>>>> W2. I
UP?PP
ARARID R BED
VEENRIK CTDEYOCUBLN
NTATCK
P
TO ALTDO O KPLTE PAR
D
ACCHOU OO GE
ORE YII  T
SOE NTVA
THATOR A WVESTUNMEO
MEEN P HYOP.G EANOAYS  T
SC
NOOVARIFCACHD SHD RA T MD SATH